hey Doug Walker here I just saw finding
dory sadly nobody else saw with me this
weekend oh poor me so yeah this is just
gonna be a review of my own and before I
talk about I should you know talk about
what I thought the first one uh Finding
Nemo I really like finding Nemo I
thought it was imagine if I thought I
had great colors and good story and
characters um if I had any gripes with
it I say the message was a little hammer
down the head but you know there's a lot
Pixar movies are like that but I I
really enjoy if I was a good film so now
we have this sequel it's getting
critical praise everybody loves it and
yeah I really like it too uh it starts
off really kind of slow and kind of dull
I kind of feel like oh this is just
Finding Nemo again and there's a chasing
with a squid kind of early on and I
realize yeah this kind of feel like just
us and finding Nemo's isn't very
interesting but as soon as it kind of
gets to this it gets this aquarium and
she comes across this octopus and I
think most you know she's trying to find
her parents that's the plot of the film
and she's trying to remember things
while doing it and as soon as they get
to this aquarium and she comes across
this octopus you come across the seals
and all these other various characters
as soon as that happens it gets good it
gets like really really good um and kind
of what else in before with the message
of the first film uh even though the
message in this is you know pre spelled
out and obvious it's not it's worked in
better than I think the first filmed in
the first film like the first two
minutes you know what the message is
gonna be any just immediately oh but
this one takes a little time they sort
of take the span of the movie to develop
it uh and then when they start repeating
things over and over it's like okay like
this this is going to be the message but
I don't know it's a more clever message
in my opinion and you know obviously a
big chunk of this movie is going to be
about memory loss make your door a
short-term memory loss and for someone
who does not have a very good memory I
really look up to a character who is
trying to go through the
tire film go through this adventure with
a really bad memory uh and I felt they
kind of represented that you know
definitely that determination but also
the frustration of dealing with that and
I like the way the characters kind of
react off of her I like that you know
they can get annoyed but they also see
like even through all this nonsense like
she's not stopping and she's not giving
up and she's discovering what she can
remember and can't remember and why she
remembers it so there's also a nice
mystery element to it as well because in
the first film
you gotta find Nemo and that's fine it
works great but there's also this
mystery of where are her parents are
they even still around um is this you
know how is she gonna find her way there
and back uh so I like that like
incorporating all that I also like that
a Nemo in this movie actually has a
bigger role I am okay not not a big role
but a bigger role because in the first
film he was the he was the goal he was
the person he had to get and he's just
kind of a generic little kid I mean he
he's fine I mean there's nothing wrong
with him uh you know and he does his
little part you know it was the pebble
in the you know a little mini aquarium
there and stuff in the fish tank you
know that's fine but in this one I felt
he had much more of a presence I mean
one he sounds older I don't know if it's
the same kid but they make him sound a
little older so that's nice to know like
he's grown up and then he also kind of
contributes he helps his father out
because they try to help find dory um
and he sort of says you know well you're
trying to follow her what would she do
well I would analyze a situation I would
look this over he's like no no what
would she do and then they try to follow
that and even dory starts to do that and
if I if I talk too much about that I'll
give a lot of stuff away but I really
like that element as well and I think
for a film that start off very much
using phrases like here we go again or
not this again or last time like I hate
sequels that use those terms because
it's just hammering in how much we're
just doing the same fill but it really
doesn't it's the big
me of this film is gonna make you think
it's just gonna be finding a Nemo
Finding Nemo again it's not it is
definitely a different film and it goes
I really like the idea I know I said
before I'm going to the aquarium because
in the first film like you see the ocean
its grand and it's beautiful but I'm
just thinking like well we're gonna do
that again and granted there are
different parts of the oh she can go to
but it's like I felt like you know we
were just here so when you go to
something as different as an aquarium
which you would think would be more
limiting because you're just kind of
stuck in one spot and the oceans the
ocean but they make it interesting and
they make it funny and they sort of do
little sad tires of like aquariums and
what it's like for you know something I
was in the wild to suddenly be entrapped
and you know the pros and cons of it
it's not a big anti-environmental or
pro-environmental it's just it's just
funny it's just this is a funny outlook
on it once again no villain thank God I
really respect these movies for doing
that um in the first one do you think is
gonna be the Willem Dafoe fish but he's
not you know he's not a villain and I
just you know not that I don't love
villains I love villains and movies
especially Disney films but there is
kind of a sense particularly with Pixar
I felt sometimes where they would just
cut throw in a bad guy because they need
a bad guy you know just and just make
this person a villain I don't know and
half the time they kind of suffer
sometimes are okay Sid in Toy Story is a
great villain ah but even this he really
a villain he's just kind of a jerky kid
but I digress so there's no real villain
in this it's just the mystery it's just
the adventure and the one scene in
particular I knew his film was really
working when I started to get like
anxiety watching it like I was so sucked
in to her finding her family and where
they are what happened to him that
there's two scenes in particular that
really kind of stuck out to me like man
I'm actually continually uncomfortable
watching this play it's supposed to be
uncomfortable one is when she gets lost
in these pipes and again her memory is
failing her and she's panicking she's
trying to remember what to do and I
think this man this movie is so good at
Sur showing you how
to keep relaxed and calm down and come
back to this Center this focus you know
that you can you know sort of get to
where you want to get and there's a
scene where she's lost in these pipes
and she it's just a good panicky moment
of just not knowing what to do and sort
of jumping the gun and getting concerned
and things are getting worse and worse
so that's very well done but the really
well done like I was like man that's
this is a strong moment is when she
finally does find out what happened to
her parents I won't give it away but
it's it for those who for those who have
seen it it's the it's the scene with
kind of like the double vision that's
the only thing I'll say if you if you've
seen this you'll know what I'm talking
about and that seemed just brought like
it felt like a panic attack I've never
had a panic attack but I get a feeling
this is what they're like like all these
things are going on around you whether
good or bad and you're just kind of
helpless to do anything about it and
it's just this really well done seeing
like I just haven't really seen anything
quite like that in a Pixar film because
you're suddenly going through a lot of
story very quickly but it's done so
effectively and it's just a really
really good emotional scene and but
that's not the only one there's a lot of
good emotional scenes in this movie and
they really legitimately work and even
the even the ending like I I can't
explain there's just all I can say is
that there's this bizarre scene
involving the song what a wonderful
world and it's not needed you could have
cut it but it was just so strange and so
enjoyably silly that you just can't
throw up your hands and say I love this
movie this is a great movie um is it
better than the first one
ah that's hard to say because it's like
it can't defence a house proportion
because the first film is probably told
a little better but I felt like there
are a lot of times where it's like okay
we're telling the story we're moving it
along now we got pause to tell you what
the message is again and you had to have
this boring moment so
with Finding Nemo I if I was to watch
I'd be watching then maybe fast-forward
the scene whether in the whale and then
maybe fast-forward the scene after they
you know when they're talking with the
Turtles about his son and stuff like
that like I price get past that stuff
but with this movie like I just fast
forward maybe the first 10 minutes and
after that it's just all incredibly
entertaining and I wouldn't skip any of
it it's just all really really good so
it kind of depends
um I think I because I like that rush I
like the continuation of the enjoyment I
probably like this one a little better
um but yeah it's a solid film and it's
really really good at all the criticisms
that people are saying about about being
so great and so wonderful sequel there
right it is really legitimately good
just like I said don't be don't be
fooled by the open you might think the
openings fine
uh and there's really not anything like
wrong with it it's just Oh
Dory's forgetting things oh she's
repeating things oh they're talking
about last time and all another thing is
chasing him I didn't realize the chases
in the water I mean I was thinking back
to the first film to I'm like yes it's
got just them swimming around this thing
chasing them sometimes they go through
something they swirl around that's
always kind of it you know that that's
never been like the highlight of the
film so when you see that first big
chasey and I was like oh is this this
going to be the movie you know is
anything okay but uh it does go
somewhere different and somewhere
interesting and it just stays in that
realm but it keeps bringing up new
things to it it's good it's a good good
film so uh I would definitely recommend
it I don't know why it's PG uh we're
getting in that stupid thing again where
it's like oh we got throw in a swear
word or some kind of innuendo to be like
you know oh we got the PG phrase see
kids that you know you don't have to
think this is dorky or anything because
we have the PG so we said something
adult and Pixar was like one of those
pioneers to bring that back like the G
film that's cool to see and now we're
going back to this dumb thing again
where it's like there is no reason for
it to be PG no reason for frozen to be
PG is no reason for inside out to be PG
I'm sure if you looked really deep you
could find some stupid but
there's really no reason all your kids
are gonna see it they're gonna love it
uh I almost think it's like a legal
thing like just to stop somebody from
suing like hey you said this was for
everybody and there's I don't like the
word no I can't I know because that
makes my kid feel bad I never say no to
my kid I don't know some source tupid
like that uh but it's a G film
I mean just assume it's a G film I don't
know why they put the P in front of it
um but it's it's really good I think
kids can see it and get a lot of good
laughs adults can see it and get a good
message and good comedy and you know
there's a lot of things I think will hit
them just as much as for the kids that's
a great Pixar Disney film should so
definitely go check it out I think
you're really gonna have a fun time with
it so that's about it I'll talk to you
later bye